for two teenage girls in afghanistan
this is what school looks like
learning from each other in their
bedrooms not a classroom
ilaha and el hammer should both be in
secondary school studying for crucial
exams but it was a taliban u-turn which
has left them denied a basic human right
that one is very bad moment sad moment
because we need
education
in future we have life we have uh
in future we need the job
[Music]
and on the final day of the grand
council meeting where 3 000 taliban
followers all men gathered to discuss
and announce policy there was no
announcement about girls and education
every girl's allowed to school and they
will education but that's not true now
i don't understand
and how do you make these girls
understand when it comes to finishing
sixth grade they'll be back home with
limited opportunities it's a policy that
is painful for teachers too
we are not the womans of 20 years ago
and they want to
calm all
womans and they
with this saying that
today we open the school tomorrow we
opened the school but nothing at the end
nothing they want to cheat all the women
of afghanistan
but the taliban today adamant they'll
fulfill their promise
what do you say directly
to girls millions of girls across
afghanistan tonight who are crying who
are disappointed because you haven't
allowed them to go to school
this could have been a pivotal moment
for the taliban's position in the eyes
of the world but many governments will
take note of their lack of inclusivity
and worsening track record on human
rights
but the condemnation wasn't just from
the international community it's come
from local leaders in afghanistan too
many believe it's against islam to stop
girls from attending school
and now with no announcement the
pressure on the taliban here in the
country and across the world
is intensifying
but once again at the heart of today's
political decision making are millions
of young women and girls for whom hope
is in short supply interim rasheed sky
news kabul